[Applause]  a 150 year old jesuit university located  in jersey city new jersey  is now in the elite eight  over to jamie  coach i just love the messages that you  tell your team you just took your time  and went over there and greeted them  what did you say to them after this win  i said what they gonna say now  anybody got something to say we can't do  this we can't do that cinderella  underdogs this deck listen i got guys  listen i got guys that just play  basketball i got a bunch of guys  i got a bunch of guys that just played  basketball and have fun that's all we do  so you're not any of those things what  are you then  [Applause]  off to the elite